okay chair
we're now live good morning members
welcome to this meeting of torridge
standards committee
and i also extend a welcome to um
any members of the general public that
are joining us on youtube
uh right without further ado uh item one
apologies for absence do we have any
yeah we have apologies from mr rule and
from councillor rossi
councillor hodson is substituting
thank you mary well uh welcome council
arts and i hope you enjoy the meeting
uh right uh two um minutes from the last
meeting
i'll go through them by page don't
hesitate
can i um can i just bring up uh on page
three before you start
uh it says uh present counselors
i was at that meeting uh councillor
clark
but my name does not appear to be on
the paperwork
uh mary can you just check and add if
appropriate please
yes chair will do thank you very much
right uh right let's go through these
pages now
three four
five
and six
nobody seems to have any issues there so
we will now move on to
declarations of interest chair you need
to vote and
accept proposals yeah
all right
well i'll propose those uh minutes do we
have a second
i'll second them right mary can you uh
take us through now please
yes sure counselor brenton
uh abstain i wasn't there
council clerk for
council ford four
councillor hawkins
four
that's five four and two abstentions
thank you uh item three declarations of
interest members with interest to
declare
should refer to the to the agenda item
and describe their nature of their
interest when the item is
being considered
or agreement between agendas part one
and part two i'll propose those
do we have a secondary chair there are
no part two so you can
just just move on if you wish very
straight on right
urgent matters um brought before
this committee but with permission of
the chair of the committee well i do
have one announcement
um since our last meeting we learned the
past
passing of councillor hal martin
i think roselock spoke for us all when
uh
when she said martin was a true
gentleman and always happy to help
hallmark of a good counsellor may we
pass our condolences to his family
thank you uh
item six right i'm gonna hand
immediately over to
stacy here to introduce this item
uh code of contact console sorry
code of conduct consultation update
thank you
thank you chair um as
members uh will have been aware the
local government association
is trying to or is currently consulting
in relation to a model code of conduct
um it's not mandatory for all um
councils to adopt the code but
and in my opinion it it would be
sensible for there to be one unified
code across all councils
um more so from torridge's perspective
as well because we've got
63 parishes and if we were working from
one code of conduct
it would make it easier for everyone
concerned
especially me as the monitoring officer
and obviously many of our members are
also members of parishes and towns
council so i think sometimes it can get
a little bit confusing having different
codes of conduct according to which
um council you're sitting on um
that being said they all obviously
follow a uh similar format and follow
the
um nolan principles
um so the the draft uh
code is it starts on page nine
um do you want me to run through each
one individually
um and maybe maybe members want to
comment
on it uh yes um that's probably a good
idea i
suspect all members have poured over
this already but it will not
hurt you to take us through okay
so stability um treating other
other counsellors and members of the
public with civility i mean
clearly we would expect that anyway and
we're very lucky to stay at torridge um
you know we have a very high standard in
that regard
um together with treating council
employees and representatives of other
organizations in a respectful manner
um really being polite and courtesy
um acknowledging obviously the right to
democracy and the right to have a debate
and then that's obviously what we expect
um when mata's become
before um committee but refraining from
any rude
and offensive behavior
not to bully and uh harass
and they've given that definition as the
a
definition um harassment
is unwanted conduct um
which degrades or an individual um
including intimidating hostile degrading
or humiliating treatment again
you know we would expect that in any
committee
and and in behavior of any
member or or council officer to be
honest
um impartiality of officers of the
council
um not to compromise
or attempt to compromise the
impartiality of anybody that works for
councils um so
officers as as members know are
politically neutral
um and uh we we obviously don't get in
involved uh in politics at all our job
is to
um put in place the decisions that are
made at members
by members at committee um
but effectively uh members should not
put
pressure on officers to change a report
or change their opinion um due to
political reasons
next one confidentiality and access to
information
um again i mean this this is already
here within our rules but not to
disclose any uh confidential information
obviously we do have confidential
information
um in relation to businesses
organizations individuals
um generally speaking obviously we do
uh those meetings in part two in private
um but it's important that that remains
in private and doesn't get into the
public
domain um that can leave us open to
legal proceedings um and can obvious
obviously um damage us and individuals
often if confidential matters get into
the public
uh domain yeah and that's also
whilst accepting that
we are to be transparent um our
decisions are generally made
in in public um
and the public are entitled to
contribute
but we do set out in our constitution
uh when members um sorry when matters
will be confidential
and it's usually um isis such as that
we're obliged by the court to keep it
confidential
or if it involves information relating
to the financial affairs or personal
affairs of a individual or company
stacy may i just uh interrupt here we've
got
councillor brenton who wishes to speak
do you want to finish your presentation
or do you want to allow members to
come in when they have a concern i think
members
i it would be preferable members come in
when they have a a
a concern right so in that case
uh councillor brenton would you like to
uh interject
please uh thank you uh yes to do with
confidentiality and access to
information basically
uh who the arbitrators are who decides
that because in the past
that's not been very satisfactory you
know if it's the chief officer
and the leader of the council decide
that
certain items should be confidential
and how can that be challenged
thank you councilman yes you're right i
mean ultimately
um it that the decision is of the chief
executive
um although i have to say very often
um if members come to me and explain um
why you want that information or need
that information um
then i will happily talk through them
with it in a
private uh meeting room or show them the
documentation
um it it's very dependent counselor
brenton upon whether you need it for
your role
um or to further something that you're
doing for your community
and you know i know we've had
conversations fairly recently where you
know
you wanted access to a document that
wouldn't ordinarily be
in the public domain and i've sat down
with you and gone through that with you
so um i suppose it all depends on the
nature of the information and what
officer holds it
but ultimately yes if it was a fuse a
decision would be down to our our chief
exec and the leader
right thank you thank you stacy if you'd
like to continue
um the next one not to bring the council
into
distribute um and that is
the uh details of that is
not to undertake behavior that is
considered dishonest and
deceitful as a member you've been
entrusted to make decisions on behalf of
your community
and your actions and behavior are
subject to greater scrutiny
and therefore what what you need to
remember is that you're representing
torridge district council
um and your views opinions actions um
uh could have a negative effect uh on on
the council
um may i interrupt you again stacy mr
clark would like to make a comment
thank you chair um i was a little bit
late putting my hand up i'm very sorry
um this is about the previous item about
confidentiality
um now when we
have the occasion to exclude the public
it's usually because the item is either
confidential
or exempt information um it seems to me
that the definition in five here
um seems to encompass exempt but calls
it confidential
we don't define in this code or how we
deal with exempt information
and there's enough confusion amongst
parish councillors between what's
confidential
and what's exempt already so i'm
wondering if the wording of this
ought to be more specific thank you
chair
thank you right stacy on we
um go just coming back um mr clark
um we can and in fact that um
from our perspective that's something
that our members have flagged in terms
of uh when we have a part two item
um members want it specifically stated
the reason why
um it's acceptable or confidential
and which makes sense because quite
often
they're asked to vote to go into part
two and they don't actually know
know the reason and behind that um
and i've i've often had the question as
to why
and i'll outline well because it's in in
relation to a legal case
or um in relation to a private
individual but i i
think it would be handy um
to uh define that um so that there can
be sort of no ambiguity in that regard
um but the legislation does
state exempt and confidential
and which falls into which category but
i i accept that it it would be handy to
have it specifically
in here and that's something that
obviously towards um
if we choose to adopt it we we can uh
amend that
to make that clear if that would help
yeah thank you
did i just come in sorry stacy can i
just
come in a second chair is that okay of
course john yeah
thank you i just just uh to make it
clear at the moment
for for the committee that this document
is still
in draft form and it's still out for
consultation um stacy and i attended a
kind of an lga workshop seminar with it
um
last week or the week before um i think
she sent the invite round to councillors
who ever wanted to
um and some of these points that you're
raising um
were mentioned at that event um and i
did mention to the chair that i would
say there is one more event that the oj
are
putting on which is on the 17th of
september
6 till 7 pm and if any count any of the
members of the
standards committee here would like to
attend let me know and i can send you
the
details to to join but the key thing is
that
there was a lot of debate around this
from the
from the attendees they've had several
of these events
so i'm assuming that quite a lot of this
will change
um so yeah that was just a bit of a
background
for members chair yeah thank you john
right stacy getting there
uh not to use your position
to um obtain an unfair advantage for you
um or any of your family or to obtain an
advantage for anybody else i mean as
as members you are in a position of
privilege um you're making decisions in
relation to matters
um and again really from our perspective
it goes without saying
um and it's already within our current
code um not to abuse your position as a
counselor
uh to obtain an unfair advantage
um next one not misusing council
resources
so um we provide
members um with access to equipment
stationery
um to enable them to conduct their role
as a counsellor
um but that's not for um
personal use um it's only to enable you
to
carry out your role as a counselor
effectively
interest registering and declaring
interests
nothing's really changed there um
obviously all our members do that as do
our parishes
um each member uh
or completes uh uh declarations of
interest that's published on our
website um i think the only thing to
bear in mind is obviously if the
situation changes then your register
needs to be
um updated
sorry can we just bring counsellor
forward please
yeah thank you chair very brief just
going back to
number nine it might be a small thing
but historically
unfortunately members have
in the past abuse there are
parking permits i just like to take this
opportunity that is
purely for when you're on council
business thank you
thank you can stacy
yep that's absolutely right councilman
ford and you know
the same as officers we're only entitled
to use the permits
um whilst we're undertaking a work for
with the council
gifts and hospitality again nothing's
changed there
um again john's team
holds torridge's register um
and any council officer or member
is to declare gifts um over 25 pounds
um members our members are generally
very good at that
um we've got a formal form but um
just dropping an email to democratic
services and that's again to go with
transparency so the public can see
um if people have had any dealings with
organizations that are doing business
with the council
and then we move on to breaches of the
code of conduct
um we have our own policy when it comes
to breaches we have our own protocol
when it
it comes to to breaches um
we have a standards committee that can
deal with breaches i
i'm very pleased to say that um
we haven't had anything of a a serious
nature
uh to warrant a formal um standards
hearing
um in in recent times
so as as john said this is out for
consultation
um the local government organization
um are hoping to present it at their
general assembly in autumn 2020
um as john john said a lot of the
consultation responses have
that have come back really relate to
standards and the sanctions that
um you know can be
imposed for breaches of um the
regulations
and i i think it's accepted that
unfortunately um the sanctions available
um are very limited um when it comes to
standards complaint and i and i think um
that was evidenced by
um a report thankfully nowhere near
torridge
in relation to the counsellor that was
recently in the press for
allegations of uh child pornography
and unfortunately that the council had
said at that stage
um there's nothing we can do unless he
receives a prison sentence so
um up until that time yes he's entitled
to remain as a councillor
serve on committees and undertake
council business and i i think
there's obviously some concern in
relation to very serious allegations
um and and as a council we don't have
any powers in relation to that
unless they receive a prison sentence of
three months or more
and then they can be removed
wishes to come back i'm sorry for the
delay council afford
but i felt it was unfair to stop stacey
did
flow no thanks for that i totally agree
um no just just to really reiterate that
a bit that basically
there's no bite to this whatsoever to be
fair
and what i would suggest which obviously
we can't do anything about but
surely if one can't carry out one's
duties one should also not pick up your
paycheck
i mean really this is actually toughness
it really is it's sad really because
you know the pointless and actually say
she's you know i'm not going to repeat
it stacey's
basically spoke about thank you um
yes i should point out that i think the
government are
still in the process of looking uh
at our role and any and and our
sanctions that
so but i suspect with covid and
everything else that's going on
it will be further delayed but i do
agree we do need to have
just a little bit of uh sanction
um can i just ask uh stacy
this is a headed code of conduct
consultation
update at this point is it appropriate
for members to suggest
anything that they would want put in or
does that come at a later date
no absolutely now is the time um to get
our consultation responses
in um i
think it's been delayed slightly because
of covered but this is our last chance
because they are hoping to present
the final format in the autumn and
can i just um come back on councillor
ford's um
comment because i i i totally agree but
i i think that it's members need to
start standing up if they're seeing
behavior
that they don't like you know you are
powerful beings
in in their committee meetings if
there's something happening or something
that you're seeing
then if you stand together and say we
don't like this on behalf of torridge we
don't want this
um to be the perception of torridge i i
think um
john and myself you know quite often
receive
um complaints uh post a committee
hearing saying
we didn't like how that happened we
didn't like that member behaving in that
way
and john and i are forever saying well
why didn't you stand up and say that
at the time you know if you if someone
was acting in a manner that you didn't
like why didn't you stand up and say
actually
we don't we don't believe that's
acceptable we don't want that happening
in our
um committees and i i think together
you're very powerful
but there seems to be a reluctance
thank you for that stacy and i would say
to all members of
this committee you are members of the
standard
committee you are the you're the sharp
end you are the very ones that should be
standing up and speaking out
uh if you're not happy stacy would you
like
written comments back from any
counsellors that wish this altered
or would you like to take them now i'm i
don't mind you i'm happy to do either
way
if members would prefer to to email
afterwards that's fine i'm happy to make
a note now and submit them whatever
whatever's preferable they there you are
members
uh it's it's whatever you like while you
just think on that
counselor wishes to come back again
did you want to come back yeah yeah if i
could briefly chair
um i do think in recent
times um there's been some emails sent
by councillors that to my opinion i did
voice that
with the leader etc uh that we're
getting close to the red line actually
to be fair
and irrespective of people's side on any
debate
that's basic on evidence facts not
conjecture and
also don't be done right childish or
vindictive
even sometimes to members of your own
group now you can pick the bones out of
that
i did bring it up because actually i
don't need to hold anybody's hand i'm
brave enough to mention it and always
have done
i might be rough as a badgers uh behind
but i believe in total integrity in my i
was born with a good name and i will not
lose that until i go to my coffin
thank you right now members
is there anybody that wishes to make a
um comment or reppin
representation for stacy to take back
or would you prefer to do it by email
i'm open for comments
counselor brenton
you're muted councillor brenton
okay clear you're here thank you right
here
and yes about the
the hearings of um of standards um
board uh meetings when they were
actually uh dealing with a case about it
being in public
i i thought that that is supposed to be
in public
all standard boards um disciplinaries
are supposed to be in public
but it doesn't seem to be on here where
where does that come in
um stacy i find that rather amazing
uh uh i would have thought that's
initially a a private thing within the
council what if
what if what if the person
who is being talked about or pulled
before us
is found to be innocent he's in public
being
um critical i just
no no no no chair if a cancer is being
accused of something it's like a court
of law
being accused of something then
obviously the council has a right to
defend themselves
and that should be in public it was the
case it should be in public
all right stacy would you like to come
back before i bring in counselor forward
again
yes chair i've i've had this
conversation with with councillor
brenton before and
and actually you know from his i think
he's got a very valid point
in fact you both have and
you know i before i took on the role of
monitoring officer um the conversation
i had the similar conversation and i was
told it was torridge's role
or torridge's standard practice to
always have these meetings in private
and i think council laws that is because
of what you're saying
in terms of an allegation has been made
uh but not proven um and
therefore you know you you're kind of
dragging them free publicly
and for something that may never be
substantiated but councillor brenton's
points quite right as well
actually um it it's a it's a public
meeting
um so i think maybe that's something for
standards to to to make a decision on
um because um the one that i was
involved with yes it was in
in private uh for that reason and i
suppose
the sanction is um that
if it's found to be upheld then the
decision of the committee
will be made public um but i think
you know there's pros and cons of both
situations and some members would be
quite happy to have it in
private some would prefer it to be
public and
i'm not sure there's an easy answer but
i can definitely see
um sides to both of it i i don't know if
john walters got an opinion
on on that is that okay
don't want me to come in and yeah yes
you've done
no it's i i totally agree with stacy um
it
can be um um two sides to to this
completely um
i think some of it would depend on the
subject matter as well so depends on
um you know kind of what what it is um
the allegations are
and um who else's may possibly be
involved in
in the investigation and the hearing
itself
but you know the the actual um
decision um if it was upheld would be
published it would be published on our
website it would be published
in on social media so i think
you know once the decision has been made
and if it was upheld
there would be public rights to see what
exactly happened but the actual
discussion and and the debate
prior to the decision being made i think
would be
a little bit harsh on the individual but
that's just a personal
question as chair i think i'm minded
we'll see we'll come to the um
future plan uh later but i might need to
put it on there but i would just ask
stacy perhaps to think
on two two sections
one that could be held uh in
um in public and one that may be
sensitive
uh that should go back to it we should
have some sort of
definition and i think it's worthy of
the future plan
now we've got two people i think
councillor ford was first
uh who wished to speak yeah thanks uh
chair having actually been through this
before um
myself and getting a two-month
suspension for not being civil
which i might concur that i probably
wasn't civil but then again
nobody accused me of lying because i
accused somebody else of being a
hypocrite and actually i will not we
retract that to this day however that
was done in public and surely all of us
come on we're here to be scrutinized i'm
happy with that
and i don't totally agree with
councillor brenton i'm sorry
if you're innocent you prove it in front
of all not beyond closed doors thank you
uh chancellor clark oh sorry i'm mr
clark
thank you thank you chair easy mistake
to make
um surely the the point is that
if this is to be held without the public
gaze
we need a vote to take it in part two
this is not confidential information
because it's not handed down by the
government
it can only be exempt information
if it's exempt information the first
decision by the by the committee has to
be
whether it's in the public interest or
not to go into part two
now that's a debate the committee has to
take and
that seems to me to be the way forward
because each case will be taken on its
merits
you may decide as a committee that this
particular case is one
where it's actually in the public
interest that this should be held in
camera
and another one you may say actually in
this case we think it should be open
and that's the time to make the decision
thank you chair
thank you for your contributions that
they are valued and i hope you remain
with us
for a little longer um right uh
i have no no one else wishing to speak
so i think that we'll move swiftly on to
item seven
best practice recommendations
daisy thank you chair um
yeah so the best practice
recommendations are on
on screen um most of which we already
undertake um practice
so best practice one local authority
should include prohibitions against
bullying and harassment in in codes of
conduct i mean
from our perspective that's fairly
standard um
i would be very surprised if there's any
local authority that doesn't
include that i think um the difficulty
is in
interpreting what bullying harassment is
occasionally um one person's
interpretation um is different from
another's um
very often um i think councillor ford's
correct
and we do um very much border um
on it occasionally um but again i i
think it's for members to stand up and
and say we don't like that behavior
can we bring in councillor brenton
please
yeah thanks sir um two of the best
practice ones here
um number two uh
to do with uh malicious allegations
well i think we should also have in
there and and political
ones as well uh somebody who's been the
victim of political
accusations of the past and also uh
vexatious ones as well
there needs to be an efficient system
of filtering them out i mean it is
unfortunately the case across the
country that you do get these
political and politically motivated
and vexatious complaints from uh
or other counselors and they really they
really must be filtered out
effectively which brings me on to six
so you must have a clear
indication of what actually qualifies
what's in the
uh public interest as opposed to
going into a confident you know a part
two situation
you know i like councillor ford you know
i too have been
the victim of this i look back on my 35
years in local government
and look at my pathway through that
and and i can say that boasting is
exemplary
except for the fact that i have been
subject to
political and vexatious complaints and
that's because of my
politics and i object to that strongly
in a democracy
and when i had a lawyer down who was
from a
big practice in london who specialized
in local government
who went round the country dealing with
standards boards
she too agreed that that was the case
but it didn't
turn out that way it just didn't turn
out that way and i was
i feel very bitter about that and still
do
and my day will come on that one but it
isn't yet
but i say we do need to have a mechanism
which
does get rid of and not allow
those political or vexatious uh items to
come before a standards board
thank you council brandon uh john i've
just got the word counsellor
in front of me i don't know who it is
that wishes to speak
sorry joe is counsellor a hodgson ah
chancellor hudson thank you mr chairman
i know i'm a uh interloper to your
affairs this morning but
um we have been considering
uh the code of conduct i've attended lga
briefings
and it's something that is very dear to
my heart
because i believe we should all treat
one
another with respect um
stacy in her initial um
introduction to this mentioned that it
would be good to have a standard
across the authority which
reflected uh adopted codes of conduct
in town and parish councils so we have
some kind of uniformity
and it is much easier to monitor
if we are all singing from the same hymn
sheet
what seems to be missing and it has been
raised at some of the
lga seminars webinars that i've attended
is that this code of conduct is
introduced
as a code of conduct both for members
elected members
and for officers of the bodies
what i notice in all the best practice
issues
is that it refers in the majority
to the conduct of members now there are
times
um and it for all of us where
anyone can be
challenged on their conduct be it an
officer or a
member and i think we slightly lose
sight of this
um and i'd like stacy sort of comments
about
how we're actually inclusive and make
sure that
we are saying this is the whole body
that this applies to
and not simply members
thank you
councillor of um council officers as
well is that is that what you mean by
all-inclusive yes
yeah i mean council offices are far
easier
in in a way to deal with um because
we've got an employee
employer relationship and if a
uh council officer behaved in
appropriate early
um during a committee meeting if they
behaved inappropriately whilst working
for torridge
then we've got a disciplinary procedure
that we we can quickly implement
um and you know if a complaint was
received then we would
deal with it the investigation under
disciplinary um the difficulty that we
have
um you know and why this is focusing on
the member code of conduct because it is
a member code of conduct as opposed to
officers although we do have an officer
protocol as well within the constitution
is that the reality
is um although we wouldn't um at times
we wouldn't want um inappropriate
behavior
there's there's nothing that that the
council can do if there is appropriate
behavior so it's kind of cajoling
and putting best practice in place to
try and encourage
um members to act appropriately um
and okay we've got very quick sanctions
in relation to employees
um already just by the very nature of
they are an employee and you've got that
employment contractual relationship
and with members we don't have that
contractual relationship you're elected
um you know we still want courage to be
um perceived in a
a good light um but
if we're not there's nothing we can do
about that in reality
and i hate to say that in a public
public meeting but
that's the truth behind it right um
councillor ford yeah sorry to uh keep
interjecting but again i do feel
strongly about
standards in fact i think it's probably
the most important thing of all
in um public life actually now
just briefly i would like to stacy to
give
a short response to this would she
agree however that senior
officers should
accept within reason i'm still being
courteous that scrutiny and challenging
can be a little bit more severe than a
junior member
because i always do look even when i go
for a drink in the pub if i've got a
young person serving me
i will probably have slightly different
you know because i
treat everybody like it could be my
daughter being spoken to
so all i'm saying is one can be
slightly more robust not bullying
i totally i'm against any form of that
shape or form
but would she not agree that senior
postholders
would accept that they could be
challenged a little bit more vigorously
than junior members thank you
yes you know absolutely and that's a
role but that that's that's why we
we try and encourage um members to come
to the more senior officers
um because you know there's no doubt i
mean
junior officers um although working for
the council don't
have um great exposure to members
you know that they're doing their role
um they're not in committees
they they don't necessarily see what's
going on they're just doing their day
job
so i accept and you know from my
perspective and john would say the same
if you've got an issue and you want to
challenge us vigorously we'd rather you
do that with us
than our junior members because that you
know the definition and
what they can accept in terms of um
the scrutiny um is far less than what we
we would expect thank you
thank you stacy you summed that up
really well so the strong wind is gonna
catch the tall trees
right so uh now had you
where have you got to coming down that
list stacey
be your members have covered their
concerns
yeah i mean i i don't think i need to
read them all through individually
um the only um the best practice seven i
should just flag up
um that's always been the same we should
have at least two independent members
and i i think
um that's really important and both from
our officers point of view and uh from
members point of view if they're
subjected to an allegation
and we only actually have one at the
moment and that's martin rules he's
fantastic um the problem is that every
um allegation that we get goes to him so
i'm a little bit
conscious um that that we're one short
at the moment
and it's a really important role within
our council
um so we probably need to do a further
push um
to at least get one more on board
we obviously we advertise that post do
we
but could we go ahead and
put the appropriate advertisements in
place
and see if we can rectify that now
coming out of
item six and seven were members
comments and you're probably still to
receive some
by email what do we do
with those do you want to bring them
back to the next meeting
as an agenda item or do we just put it
on to the forward plan
your guide here please um i
would be very interested to see the
final version that the lga
present after the consultation responses
so
i think when they present the final
version that will need to come back to
standards and standards will need to
decide
um whether we want to formally adopt it
or
adopt it with some adaptations
right thank you thank you for taking us
through
uh best practice so um let's move to the
forward plan because there's nothing on
there at the moment
um members do you have any thoughts here
come on members this won't do
we're an active committee is there
anything that you feel we should be
uh looking at right i've got a quick
response there we've got
um two members um john
i don't know who was first if you could
mr clark first chair mr clark
thank you jeff i'm sorry council brendan
um
could we put on the agenda a replacement
for me please
i'm still here at the moment but um it
won't continue that way
right um is that something for the
forward plan or
is that down to another advertisement
i mean i'm not sure how that role is
covered is it by advertisement
or invitation well i i'm not sure either
chair because
i believe it's the case that my um
that having a parish and town rep is not
mandatory
under the um provisions um stacey you
might know that
um but it's something that torrid has
always done
well and and i think we've you
the proof of the pudding uh you
are your contributions are always
constructive
and worthwhile and i think you do need
um to be replaced i don't know whether
we circulate the parish councils
looking for a volunteer if if you could
put that in hand
to um john that would be really
uh really good uh councillor brenton
thank you chair uh well deal with that
point uh straight away there is a demon
association of uh parish and town
councils
it would be good to uh ask them if they
would circulate amongst the
uh parish and towns of um
torridge asking for a volunteer or
giving them at least the opportunity to
put somebody forward
to uh to do that role uh the other thing
is is
also to do with um the selection of the
independent members i think that should
be done better and it has been
in the past which uh there's a bit of
smoke and mirrors going on there
and um i mean we had one so-called
independent person who then stood as a
conservative um
uh candidate for a council you know how
independent is that i think
the public need to be perceived that
those independent people
are truly independent which means i
think that
any selection panel at least the
group leaders should be consulted on
that and not
the gift of um leader of the council
right can i ask i think it's probably
john
uh if we advertise one other item sorry
to do the timetable clearly we don't
need to
we should wait until the uh lga come
back with uh
their final final draft don't you think
post that final draft and then
and then have a meeting right
um john i can see that there are two
people who wish to speak but i can't
see okay let me let me come back to you
on the the query that you had about the
advertising
so yes we we for the last time we had
two paris reps we sent an email around
to the paris clerks
asking for volunteers
there was a brief application to be
completed and then
um there was an interview process with
the senior officer
the leader and the chair of standards
and then there were two successful
applicants so we can send out to the
parish
parishes again asking for volunteers if
that's what the
committee wish and as mr clark said
it isn't a necessity to have
the parish reps but it is most certainly
um good practice or best practice
to have that um and that came through
from the localism act
um i just interject and ask
is the independent person subject to the
same interview panel
the the independent person is not a
member of
the committee so it's slightly different
the independent person works closely
with a monitoring officer
and gives advice to the monitoring
officer and to the
um committee from an independent
point of view so that that is a slightly
different
interview process but just following up
on
um council brenton's concerns
how is that independent person selected
is he does he have an interview or
is it an appointment well now he
yes he does have an interview and i
stacy did you do the last one i can't
recall
no i haven't been involved in in the um
previous appointment of the independent
person
um i've got no objection to whoever
wants to be involved in those interviews
um you know
again you know i i would agree with
councillor brenton that it is absolutely
essential that they are
genuinely independent i'm i think we're
very lucky with the one that we've got
at the moment
um i think the difficulty is is that
um we have we just haven't
had uh many applications and the last
two times we've
gone out we've had no applications at
all
um so when we say appoint someone that's
truly independent
actually we need to encourage people to
to get their application in and
at the moment that's why we've we've
just had the one for a considerable
period of time because i
think john will correct me if i'm wrong
we've advertised at least twice
um in recent history and we've not had
any applications whatsoever
for the role it is a voluntary role
again
um so it's got to be someone who's got
enough time to dedicate
to it and i think it's tough because if
anyone's got any suggestions
then then by all means or knows anyone
who would be good for the role
um you know we would happily speak to
them
yeah we have we have advertised it three
times i believe um
each time in the local press and um
on social media and on the website so um
stacey's absolutely right we we
didn't have any um expressions of
interest
right the life members of this committee
and say if you know of anybody please
put there
have a chat with them and put their name
forward right we have two people
john waiting to speak chancellor ford
his first chat
thank you yeah thanks chair um i did
mention this before and it might be just
me that's got a
bit of a personal problem here um
picking up on what kind of brenton said
you're absolutely right and
i have noticed we've advertised and
we're struggling to get people you know
given up time in that i understand that
but it is about being truly independent
because
just briefly i think paris councillors
are the same
as us whereby you've got to declare
membership of
outside bodies freemasonry etc because i
will touch on freemasonry because you
know i'm sorry
um it does i've got an issue with that
whether it's my fault or not
does the independent person that was i'm
assuming wouldn't have to declare
whether they're a member should they be
a member which at the moment is not
relevant because we can't even get
anybody but
you know every independent is
independent that's what i'm asking
thank you
thank you mr clark yeah thank you chair
um i took part in the last interviews
for an independent person and i'd like
to reassure councillor brenton
i didn't see any smoke and mirrors um
there were three applicants
and they were all interviewed um as far
as i'm concerned in a professional way
they were all asked the basic questions
the same questions without any slant
and they were all asked supplementary
questions depending upon
the responses they gave to the first set
of questions um and we did choose one
person out of that
who's no longer uh uh with us
um now and
and and the committee if you'd like or
the panel that interviewed them from
memory was the monitoring officer the
chair of the standards
um the uh and i was asked to take part
being um shall we say one of the um old
older brethren here
um and uh i don't think there was any
other
officer involvement there was no
political um
slant on this at all and i'd also like
to say that
the the um independent person
that we lost a couple of years ago and
yes that's true he did stand
subsequently as
um a a councillor uh under under a
a party banner um but i'm not aware
that he at any time demonstrated
party membership uh prior to
the time when he left as as an
independent person
and can we please be careful that we do
call them independent persons
not independent members there's a
confusion here that we mustn't fall down
thank you uh thank you very much
um have we succeeded in getting anything
onto the forward plan
or appear not
right well first of all i would just
like to say
in case our paths don't cross again
um mr clark thank you so much for your
contributions they've always been
very valued and should you move away
lucky the area you move into
uh right um account says there's no
items
on part two so that really draws the
meeting to an end
thank you for your attendance
and have a good day thank you thank you
john thank you stacey